con gran desconcierto pero recibió la
noticia de los siete médicos contagiados
con kobe 19 por su parte diversas
federaciones de trabajadores de salud
anuncian jornadas de protesta que
señalan se realizarán entre el 6 y el 12
de abril ellos van a salir a las calles
del país a reclamarle al gobierno del
presidente francisco sagasti mejores
condiciones laborales y una modificación
radical al plan de vacunación los
servidores rechazan la decisión del
estado peruano de vacunarlos con la
dosis destino fan cuando ésta no ha
publicado los resultados de sus ensayos
clínicos en el país hechos irregulares
en torno al proceso de vacunación ha
aumentado la desconfianza de los
ciudadanos y el rechazo a las vacunas
según un último sondeo el 39 por ciento
de peruanos se resiste a recibir las
vacunas según el ministerio de salud
pero lleva más de 1.500.000 contagiados
y más de 52.000 fallecidos por el código
19 las autoridades han anunciado que a
partir del miércoles el país recibirá
200.000 vacunas pzifer por semana y para
prevenir anomalías el presidente
francisco sagasti prometió que se
contará con una ley
y una secuencia de las personas que
inmuniza eran y esta será pública
mientras tanto servidores de salud de
cuatro regiones del perú advierten que
los hospitales han colapsado debido a la
presencia de la variante brasileña
médicos y enfermeras alertan que ya no
hay camas en las unidades de cuidados
intensivos ni oxígeno en los centros de
salud